help me clear something up because i  heard a rumor  that you auditioned for the role of han  solo  and if is that true first of all  yes but you know at that time i think  you know hundreds of actors audition for  that part  i also auditioned for love story you  know again it must have  been hundreds of people you auditioned  for the ryan o'neill part in love story  yes i auditioned for superman and and so  did  everybody else so i didn't get the part  and it's a good thing because i wouldn't  have been much good  well i did i beg to disagree i'm now  rethinking  all of those roles with you in them  and i i think you as han solo would have  been fantastic no  slight on harrison ford i think he did a  fine job  but uh i would have loved your would be  very different han solo  very different but too much maybe like  chewbacca  still you know  you would have just done a lot of you  think maybe  too much too much